[Music]
hard left spokesmen almost never break
character as they purvey their nonsense
they give the impression to all the
world that they really believe their own
half-truths lies and distortions
however investigative journalist dexter
vans Isle reported recently an alga
minor something very interesting about
Muslim activist Cory sailor who is the
managing director of the security and
rights at rethink media and former
director of the department to monitor
and combat Islamophobia at the Hamas
linked Council on american-islamic
relations or care sailor recently
revealed probably inadvertently that he
knows the truth beyond the Islamophobia
victimhood propaganda that care and it's
allied organizations tirelessly pump out
vans Eyal said this speaking at a
counter Islamophobia conference at the
University of Minnesota Saylor admitted
that anti-muslim sentiment is driven in
part by jihadists who kill in the name
of Allah Saylor conceded during a
conference session entitled how
Islamophobia became mainstream that
violent extremist groups that claim that
Islam gives sanction to their actions
contribute to Islamophobia Saylor
punctuated his statement with an
emphatic there's no doubt about it
according to Vans Isle he added that to
not acknowledge the impact that groups
like Isis have had on attitudes about
Islam and its adherence would be to not
have a complete conversation now this is
highly unusual it could even have been a
slip on sailors part I wouldn't be
surprised if his former bosses at Kerr
Nihad Awad and Ibrahim Hooper call him
in for a reprimand the usual line that
Kerr takes along with its leftist and
Islamic supremacists allies is that
Islamophobia is entirely a product of a
well-heeled and sinister cabal of
Islamophobes and that they have somehow
succeeded in spreading fear and hatred
of Muslims among a large segment of
American population solely by means of
malicious and mendacious propaganda the
care line which of course is eerily
power
by the leftist establishment media is
they small lavishly funded unfortunately
not an interconnected group of
Islamophobes including most notably
Pamela Geller Frank Gaffney John Gwang
dolo David Horowitz and me are out of
our insatiable desire for profit making
Americans hate the profit we are the
story goes a clique of racists and
bigots who have decided to make people
hate Muslims because we supposedly make
a handsome profit from that hate this is
all of course total nonsense and a
former high-ranking care official has
now admitted that he knows it's nonsense
the obvious reality is that no one would
have a negative view of Islam or Muslims
at all were it not for jihad massacres
boasts an imminent takeover mass rapes
by Muslim gangs and so on and so on
cares extravagant claims about our clout
are oddly out of sync with the contempt
that it keeps upon us but it gives us so
much credit because the alternative is
too terrifying for its officials to
contemplate to admit that Islam's
negative image may be the fault of
Muslims not non Muslims the last thing
that care and it's leftist allies want
to do is acknowledge that if any
Americans really have negative
impressions of Islam it is because of
the actions of Muslims who commit acts
of terror while screaming Allahu Akbar
and pointing to the Quran and Muhammad
to justify what they have done if
Americans dislike Islam it's because of
Osama bin Laden Abu Bakr al Baghdadi
Anwar al-awlaki Nidal Malik Hasan
Dzhokhar and Tamerlan tsarnaev and the
rest
not because of Gellar Gaffney Horowitz
and me but to admit this would focus on
welcome attention on the fact that these
men and other jihad terrorists were
devout Muslims acting upon the texts and
teachings of Islam yet now that is just
what Saylor has done in doing this he
has endangered the entire Islamophobia
narrative he has heralded the day when
the entire Islamophobia victimhood
industry with all its conferences think
tanks and endowed chairs will collapse
under the weight of reality that day is
coming and Saylor knows it's coming
maybe even Nihad Awad Annie
Hooper no it's coming too which is why
they're so insistent on pushing their
narrative at every opportunity now
before it's too late
thus despite sailors admission the
Islamophobia victimhood industry will
continue to defame and vilify those who
call attention to the reality of jihad
terror it's telling that care and its
allies devotes so much of their time and
energy to demonizing and stigmatizing
those who call attention to jihad
activity and its justifications within
Islamic teaching do care and the left
really want to intimidate people into
not opposing the advancing jihad so that
it can advance unimpeded it sure seems
that way
I'm Robert Spencer a Shulman fellow for
the David Horowitz Freedom Center and
director of jihad watch this video has
been brought to you by the Center for
security policy
[Music]